[Music]
Elon Musk is confident that large-scale
data and deep learning can solve the
autonomous driving problem what are your
thoughts on the limits possibilities of
deep learning in this space I was it's
obviously part of the solution I mean I
don't think we'll ever have a set
driving system or at least not in the
foreseeable future that does not use
deep Ronnie you put it this way so in
the history of sort of engineering
particularly is sort of sort of a I like
systems is generally your first phase
where everything is built by hand and
there is a second phase and that was the
case for autonomous driving you know 23
years ago there's a phase where this a
little bit of running is used but
there's a lot of engineering that's
involved in kind of you know taking care
of corner cases and and putting limits
etc because the learning system is not
perfect and then I as technology
progresses we end up relying more and
more on learning that's the history of
character recognition so history of
speech recognition computer vision that
when I crush processing and I think the
same is going to happen with with the
time is driving that currently the the
the methods that are closest to
providing some level of autonomy some
you know decent level of autonomy where
you don't expect a driver to kind of do
anything is where you constrain the
world so you only run within you know
100 square kilometers or square miles in
Phoenix but the weather is nice and the
roads are wide which is what Weimer is
doing you completely over engineer the
car with tons of light hours and
sophisticated sensors that are too
expensive for consumer cars but they're
fine if you just run a fleet
and you engineer the thing the hell out
of the everything else you you map the
entire world so you have complete 3d
model of everything so the only thing
that the perception system has to take
care of is moving objects and and and
construction and sort of you know things
that that weren't in your map and you
can engineer a good you know slam system
or eye stuff right so so that's kind of
the current approach that's closest to
some level of autonomy but I think
eventually the long term solution is
gonna rely more and more on learning and
possibly using a combination of
supervised learning and model-based
reinforcement or something like that
you